I'm getting a couple of wood 2x4s ready because
my 4 foot magnifying lens needs a sturdy frame.
I hacked this out of an old TV in a previous
video, but it's too flimsy to use on it's
own. We need something that's super cheap
to make, but sturdy and easy to use, and I've
got an idea that just might work.
Measuring the sides of the lens seems like
a good place to start, so let's do that and
then mark the wood for custom cutting. It's
best to use as little wood as possible so
I'm gonna use this table saw to rip these
studs in two. This shouldn't compromise the
integrity of the frame at all, and it will
cut the weight in half! These 2x4's are now
2x2's, and we'll need to cut a groove right
down the middle. Once I've got the center
lined up, I'll lower the blade down to about
3/4" and get the saw spinning. As the beam
glides over the blade, I'm happy to see that
it cuts a clean 3/16" groove. This is the
groove that our lens will fit into and sliding
the pieces into place proves that the cuts
were good. The edges match up and the frame
looks functional, but before we secure it,
we'll need to drill some holes right in the
center to accommodate this 3" bolt. I've added
a rubber washer to the bolt and pushed it
through the hole, then when this piece goes
back in place we can still access the threads.
Oops, I almost forgot. I wanted to add a more
finished look to this frame, so I'll add a
1/2" chamfer bit to my router, and trim the
outer edges. I built this router right into
my workbench so I'd have a lot of room for
bigger projects. Look for how to build this router table in a different project. These simple
cuts are quickly giving the frame a more professional
look. Ok, those are done so now I can retract
my router bit and lay these support blocks
down. The lens goes overtop, and these blocks
are helping prevent the lens from warping.
When we've got one of the corners lined up,
we can drill a pilot hole, and add a 3" wood
screw. That's holding well, so let's repeat
that on the other 3 corners. Drilling these
holes first, helps prevent the wood from splitting
when the screws go in. The Scorcher lens is
framed, and we can put that off to the side
and get to work on making a collapsable "A"-frame.
This time we'll need to cut two 5' lengths
of 2x4 and rip them into 2x2's the same as
the others. I wanna make a hinged frame,
but before we do let's router these edges
as well, and save some of the saw dust for
a future charcoal making project. Alright,
my table is clean again, and I'm gonna
try an idea for a modified hinge with these
eye-screws. These screws were 6 for a buck,
and we'll only need 4. Holes are drilled in
the center of the the chamfered edge, and
then these screws are tightened to where they
line up nicely with each other. They stay
together closed, and fully open, so I'm hopeful
this is gonna work. It's time to join the
"A"-frame with the Scorcher lens. A washer
and nut go on the bolt, and now I'm cutting
this barbed sprinkler line coupling to act
as a spacer. The barb is on, with a washer
on either end, and the eye-screws are added
next, followed by washer, barb, washer, and
secured in place with a wing nut. Everything
is duplicated on the other side, and these
frame legs pivot just the way I was hoping.
Next we'll need to measure the distance between
the legs and cut 4 more pieces of wood to
act as support braces. When those are roughed
in place, let's measure about 10" from the
Scorcher frame and make some marks.
When we've drilled the holes and added the screws, the frame is pretty
much done. The Scorcher lens rotates a full
360 degrees and seems relatively sturdy. One
more thing I wanna try is adding an adjustable
tensioner, so I'm cutting a scrap piece of
1/8" hardboard into a strip about 2" wide
and 18" long. Then I'll adjust the saw to
cut a groove in the center stopping about
1-1/2" from the ends. A hole is drilled in
the frame 10" from the top and the band is
connected to the frame with a 3" bolt and
some wide metal washers. A wing nut will hold
that together loosely, then this other end
of the strap connects to the side of the pivoting
frame about 5" from the fulcrum. Oops, that's
a little too tight, so I'll back it off a
touch, and give it a test. I can still rotate
the lens nearly 360 degrees, but now I have
the benefit of being able to position, and
tighten this securely at any angle I want.
The frame looks great and totally exceeds
my expectations for functionality and practical
use. The best part is we made the whole thing
custom for about $8! That's it for now. If
you liked this project, perhaps you'll like
some of my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com